Caption: hi everyone this talk is about extremely
Caption: typed to strongly type with typescript
Caption: just want to start off by saying a big
Caption: thanks to our sponsors
Caption: so i'll start off with who i am um
Caption: currently working at vgw as a senior
Caption: software engineer and i'm pretty much
Caption: all the time working on typescript and
Caption: node so most of my stuff is on the back
Caption: end but obviously i do some front-end
Caption: stuff as well also in typescript
Caption: i've been using typescript and node
Caption: since the very early days i used to
Caption: think that if you really really pushed a
Caption: language to its absolute limit you'd be
Caption: lucky enough to discover a bug that
Caption: wasn't your bug was actually a bug in
Caption: the compiler
Caption: and over the years of using typescript
Caption: because it's been you know it's started
Caption: small and it's become more and more
Caption: popular but i've discovered a lot of
Caption: those bugs so either i've really been
Caption: pushing it to the limit or it's a very
Caption: buggy project i think the truth is a bit
Caption: of both
Caption: although i'd like to say that now i
Caption: rarely open new issues on typescript so
Caption: it's a really solid platform now
Caption: same with node
Caption: i also like to contribute to open source
Caption: projects
Caption: and maintain a few of my own and also
Caption: like to mentor at coda dojo in perth
Caption: so i thought it was relevant to actually
Caption: talk a little bit about who you are as
Caption: an audience as well because i figured
Caption: who would be interested in a talk about
Caption: typescript and
Caption: it's it's a well-known language but not
Caption: everyone's using it yet
Caption: and i figured that there's probably a
Caption: few different groups in the audience so
Caption: um i i guess most people here are
Caption: developers
Caption: some of you might be more familiar with
Caption: dynamically typed languages if you're
Caption: working on the front end you're probably
Caption: using javascript there's also there'd
Caption: also be a bunch of people
Caption: who have familiar with php and python in
Caption: particular if you're doing working in
Caption: sciences or anywhere for that matter
Caption: other popular languages are what they
Caption: call the statically typed languages and
Caption: they're things like c sharp java haskell
Caption: c plus plus
Caption: things that require you to
Caption: explicitly add types to your code and
Caption: satisfy the compiler that your code is
Caption: correct
Caption: uh and there might also be some people
Caption: here already using typescript um so i'm
Caption: aware that i'm probably speaking to
Caption: several different people and who have
Caption: different questions so if you're already
Caption: using dynamic languages you're probably
Caption: asking yourself like why do i want to
Caption: add steps why do i want to add a build
Caption: step and all these checks it's just
Caption: going to slow me down so you know what's
Caption: the deal
Caption: if you're mainly used to using
Caption: statically typed languages already
Caption: you're probably wondering well why would
Caption: i do the next project in node sorry in
Caption: typescript what's in it for me what am i
Caption: going to gain and if you're already
Caption: using typescript maybe you're here
Caption: because you want to
Caption: feel awesome and maybe pick up something
Caption: new so i'm going to try and cover
Caption: different questions for different people
Caption: right so what is this talk actually
Caption: about stringly typed code what does it
Caption: mean
Caption: i think as tech people we we should
Caption: probably start with a definition
Caption: so
Caption: the definition for this talk um and i
Caption: should just as background
Caption: the the the term itself stringly type
Caption: code the name of what we're talking
Caption: about came from as far as i can figure
Caption: out from a 2012 article on coding horror
Caption: there was an article titled new
Caption: programming jargon and it's worth having
Caption: a look at this because it got some other
Caption: funny ones on there as well but it had
Caption: an entry for stringly typed code with
Caption: this meme meme cat on it which sort of
Caption: sums it up you know can i have can i use
Caption: a string to store a date value so there
Caption: was a whole big text blurb i won't bore
Caption: you with that but the the summary of
Caption: what it said was that it's basically
Caption: about overusing strings for too many
Caption: things
Caption: and listing some some issues that come
Caption: out from doing that i'm not going to go
Caption: with that exact definition for this talk
Caption: because things have moved on we've got
Caption: new possibilities with our languages and
Caption: our tools and our platforms so it's not
Caption: just really overuse of strings but it is
Caption: a pattern in the code and this is the
Caption: definition i'm going to go with my talk
Caption: so it's a coding pattern
Caption: where you can make trivial errors in the
Caption: code which pass static checks
Caption: but they fail at runtime
Caption: so i'm going to go through each of those
Caption: highlighted bits of that definition to
Caption: just sort of explain more what i mean
Caption: about each of those now
Caption: so what do i mean by a coding pattern
Caption: first of all it's not a bug stringly
Caption: typed code is not a bug it's usually
Caption: found in systems that are actually
Caption: working so we're not talking about a bug
Caption: here we're talking about a coding
Caption: pattern
Caption: uh
Caption: the issue is usually more about what
Caption: happens when someone needs to change the
Caption: code they don't ever worked on a system
Caption: that never needed to change
Caption: it's probably pretty rare
Caption: every system i've ever worked on there's
Caption: always new requirements even if they're
Caption: not new requirements for customers maybe
Caption: there's new regulations there's things
Caption: that have to be changed so when the code
Caption: has to change that old code string type
Caption: code and all the other code has to be
Caption: modified and refactored at times
Caption: so i'd say it's not a bug but stringly
Caption: type code is something that's going to
Caption: multiply your cost it's a cross
Caption: multiplier or a speed bump you know it's
Caption: a little bit hard to sail in your cool
Caption: yacht when it's covered in barnacles on
Caption: the bottom and i'd describe stringly
Caption: type code as something that just really
Caption: slows you down from refactoring from
Caption: producing new features because you're
Caption: always worried about what you're going
Caption: to break and not know what it is
Caption: and i should also say you can write
Caption: stringly sorry it's a it's a major
Caption: source of brittleness in code so this is
Caption: what i was just saying about worrying
Caption: about well if i change something over
Caption: here i have no idea maybe all the front
Caption: end is depending on this thing but
Caption: there's no actual warning there's no
Caption: build tool that i run and it tells me
Caption: how you broke page three five and seven
Caption: it's just you just run it and you see
Caption: and the problem with that is that maybe
Caption: you run it and you don't see a problem
Caption: but your end user runs it and then they
Caption: run into some huge problem
Caption: you can write stringly type code in any
Caption: language it is not just something about
Caption: dynamic languages we mentioned before
Caption: you can do it in static languages just
Caption: as easily
Caption: so we i mentioned also that it's a
Caption: coding pattern
Caption: involving trivial errors now i just want
Caption: to be clear that we're talking about
Caption: trivial code changes that you might
Caption: introduce when you have to do a new
Caption: feature i'm not talking that saying the
Caption: outcome's trivial because otherwise the
Caption: whole talk is trivial the outcome could
Caption: actually be really major it could be
Caption: bugs in production that costs money to
Caption: rectify but what we're talking about is
Caption: bugs that you could introduce by just
Caption: changing a couple of letters in in your
Caption: source code
Caption: and then having no warning until the
Caption: thing slips all the way out to
Caption: production so yeah stringly type code
Caption: can be a big deal
Caption: the other thing about these errors is
Caption: that
Caption: they are possible to detect without even
Caption: running the code you can look at the
Caption: code and if you look well enough that's
Caption: what code reviews are for right but also
Caption: that's what static checkers are for
Caption: build tools compilers and so on these
Caption: are the kind of errors that can be
Caption: checked statically
Caption: um so in the talk later on i'm going to
Caption: go into detail into a whole bunch and um
Caption: so i'm just going to really briefly
Caption: outline a sort of category you know a
Caption: list of these sort of errors that we're
Caption: going to come across so the first one is
Caption: kind of the bread and butter of type
Caption: systems and that's typos so i've just
Caption: got an example there where i'm
Caption: referencing a property
Caption: and i've got two different spellings
Caption: one's right one's wrong depending on
Caption: your system
Caption: you may not find out about that until
Caption: later on and depending on when that
Caption: piece of code actually runs
Caption: so another uh
Caption: stringly typed
Caption: error
Caption: is when you've got implicit connections
Caption: between different parts of your system
Caption: but there's no tool that can actually
Caption: work out that these are the same concept
Caption: so here i've got an example where
Caption: you've got some state in your code and
Caption: over somewhere else in html you're using
Caption: um some sort of templating language to
Caption: get that piece of state displayed on the
Caption: screen but
Caption: you may have a system that either does
Caption: or doesn't make a link between those two
Caption: things so if you go and refactor your
Caption: estate do you find out that your front
Caption: end is broken well it depends and we'll
Caption: look at some techniques around that
Caption: later
Caption: another one is transposed values so you
Caption: know here's an email function we're
Caption: sending an email
Caption: there's alice bob hi and hello is it
Caption: really obvious from looking at that
Caption: who's the sender and who's the receiver
Caption: and what's the subject and what's the
Caption: message the message body well you
Caption: probably have to go and look at the
Caption: implementation of the function some ide
Caption: tools will help you and they'll tell you
Caption: which one's which but even then
Caption: if your variables aren't named very well
Caption: the compiler's not going to tell you if
Caption: you put them the wrong way around or
Caption: change something do it in the wrong
Caption: order so that's transposed values this
Caption: one i just call apples to oranges
Caption: because
Caption: most programming languages they have a
Caption: type called a string and a very closely
Caption: related one called a number so stringly
Caption: type code's not always about strings in
Caption: this case i've got an example that's
Caption: about a number but you can do this kind
Caption: of thing with strings as well so i've
Caption: got a
Caption: variable called m
Caption: and i'm calling feet to meters and
Caption: passing in m and getting back something
Caption: which i'm calling f so you can kind of
Caption: see the the problem here is that we've
Caption: mixed up feet with meters and we've
Caption: called a function converting the wrong
Caption: way but the type system it's going to
Caption: allow it because they're both numbers it
Caption: doesn't know the difference between one
Caption: another that's a units of measure
Caption: problem
Caption: another problem is conflicting
Caption: definitions and a classic example is
Caption: systems that rely on feature flags or
Caption: something maybe picking up from
Caption: environment variables and you look
Caption: around the code base and you see
Caption: references to environment variables
Caption: embedded in different files and
Caption: sometimes you'll see the same
Caption: environment variable referenced in
Caption: different places but perhaps parsed in
Caption: different ways or given different
Caption: defaults so
Caption: i'd call that string type code because
Caption: you've got different things that are
Caption: supposed to be one thing but they're
Caption: actually possibly out of sync with each
Caption: other and if you change one
Caption: it doesn't necessarily tell you that
Caption: you've got something else that's now
Caption: inconsistent
Caption: and finally we'll look at brittle
Caption: control flow so it's really easy to
Caption: actually write control flow constructs
Caption: using strings
Caption: is an example there where you know we're
Caption: checking if something is ahead we do one
Caption: thing otherwise we do something else
Caption: because it must be a tails well unless
Caption: someone actually stamps something other
Caption: than heads and then you're going to get
Caption: some wrong control flow
Caption: so going back to our definition we said
Caption: these are the sort of errors that pass
Caption: static checks static checks is just when
Caption: either humans or tools inspect the code
Caption: the source code you don't even have to
Caption: run it you just look at it
Caption: um so just to pass these checks it just
Caption: means that your ide is not telling you
Caption: anything or if you're using a text
Caption: editor it's just text so you don't get
Caption: any warnings there
Caption: if you've got a build step that's saying
Caption: yep it's all fine no problems at all
Caption: uh
Caption: you yourself don't spot any errors if
Caption: you wrote this code and a reviewer
Caption: doesn't spot any errors so that's what
Caption: we mean it gets all the way through the
Caption: process
Caption: um i should just briefly mention unit
Caption: tests because this is the classic thing
Caption: if you're in a dynamic language you
Caption: realize you should rely quite heavily on
Caption: unit tests so on a technicality they're
Caption: not static checks because you have to
Caption: run the code to actually run the unit
Caption: test but they run so close to your code
Caption: that they're obviously really good and
Caption: really valuable
Caption: there are a few drawbacks with them for
Caption: our purposes today
Caption: first of all you don't get any help in
Caption: your ide from from unit tests generally
Caption: also they're human written so they
Caption: suffer from a lot of the same problems
Caption: that the code itself basically like if a
Caption: human
Caption: could write perfect unit tests they
Caption: probably don't need them
Caption: so
Caption: tests tend to uh have flaws in them they
Caption: might have bugs in them themselves and
Caption: they
Caption: usually miss coverage of your code
Caption: so they're definitely useful but they're
Caption: rarely as good as something that can be
Caption: automated to do to cover 100 of whatever
Caption: what kind of errors it can detect
Caption: and finally failing at runtime
Caption: uh the later you catch an error
Caption: it's often more costly to fix as this
Caption: this bridge illustrates which is a fake
Caption: by the way
Caption: um
Caption: there can be costs on your end users and
Caption: that may then well not cost like in
Caption: hassles or inconvenience or reputational
Caption: damage whatever these costs come back on
Caption: onto your own company and yeah the
Caption: impact on your business reputation lost
Caption: revenue and then engineering costs to
Caption: rectify these things so those costs can
Caption: really escalate so extremely type code
Caption: it's not trivial really
Caption: it's something that really impacts
Caption: businesses
Caption: okay moving on
Caption: i just want to come back to
Caption: uh how i said in the room we've probably
Caption: got people coming from dynamic language
Caption: background static language backgrounds
Caption: um
Caption: i think that they often really shape how
Caption: we think about solving problems with
Caption: code so i just want to like focus on
Caption: that for a little bit
Caption: so remember i showed this diagram before
Caption: we had some static and dynamic language
Caption: people
Caption: um
Caption: [Music]
Caption: there's something that barney
Caption: strausstrup who was the inventor of c
Caption: plus once said he said there's two types
Caption: of programming languages there's
Caption: programming languages that everyone
Caption: complains about and there's programming
Caption: languages that nobody uses
Caption: um
Caption: i think it sort of goes to show that
Caption: there's uh you know there's a bunch of
Caption: memes around languages basically you
Caption: know there's things that people love to
Caption: hate about all the different languages
Caption: maybe the ones you're using maybe the
Caption: ones that other people are using so just
Caption: for a moment let's just take a look at
Caption: some of these memes not just the bad
Caption: side but also the good side
Caption: so let's start with dynamic dynamically
Caption: type languages things like javascript
Caption: and python and things like that
Caption: supporters
Caption: might visualize it this way
Caption: super fast rapid development you're
Caption: really productive in these languages
Caption: nothing slows you down you just type it
Caption: out and you run it if it doesn't work
Caption: just tweak it run it again until you get
Caption: it right you've got a prototype out the
Caption: door in no time at all
Caption: they're flexible they're really low
Caption: friction there's not a lot of ceremony
Caption: you just get you just get stuff done
Caption: and you can usually with these languages
Caption: you can really express a lot with a
Caption: small amount of code
Caption: okay
Caption: people who
Caption: are detractors of dynamic languages what
Caption: sort of meme might they put on this so
Caption: the one i came up with was this guy
Caption: um
Caption: it said that sometimes with dynamic
Caption: language you just throw code at the wall
Caption: and you see what sticks
Caption: they often don't catch basic errors and
Caption: that's a lot a lot of the sort of things
Caption: we're talking about here even typos can
Caption: slip through and not be found until
Caption: later on
Caption: and if these systems get large they can
Caption: really cause some refactoring nightmares
Caption: and i've had a few of those nightmares
Caption: myself
Caption: so let's go across and give the
Caption: treatment to the statically tight
Caption: languages now so starting with the good
Caption: stuff
Caption: i just thought that that was a nice
Caption: visualization of really smoothly running
Caption: orchestra of machinery and that's you
Caption: know that's statically typed
Caption: languages like java and c-sharp running
Caption: with all their factories and things you
Caption: know everything is a
Caption: symphony um
Caption: also they catch your errors right away
Caption: so you know you're not likely to put
Caption: buggy stuff out there because it catches
Caption: a whole bunch of stuff straight away for
Caption: you so that's good and there's lots of
Caption: great tooling for these languages
Caption: um and you can really scale up that
Caption: they're designed for that on the
Caption: detractor side
Caption: uh
Caption: i came up with this one so there's a
Caption: toilet there and we're just trying to
Caption: flush the toilet but there's this whole
Caption: massive machinery
Caption: and
Caption: this is kind of the rigmarole of what
Caption: you sometimes run into depending on the
Caption: kind of project you're working on but
Caption: you know basically you've always got to
Caption: appease the compiler your thing is not
Caption: going to run until the compiler is
Caption: satisfied that it can prove that there's
Caption: no type errors in your code so you've
Caption: got to come up with types you've even
Caption: maybe need to change your api to match
Caption: what the compiler is able to do
Caption: and often you end up with a lot of
Caption: boilerplate code
Caption: changing between the types that you came
Caption: up with or the classes and so on to some
Caption: sort of
Caption: text representation that you can store
Caption: in a database or sender of a http
Caption: request
Caption: and finally abstract signature proxy
Caption: factory beans so i thought that was a
Caption: sort of a made-up thing but i googled it
Caption: and it took me straight to the
Caption: documentation page for the actual thing
Caption: so it's a real thing
Caption: complexity what we're talking about here
Caption: okay they seem like they're really
Caption: different ends of the spectrum but what
Caption: about common ground
Caption: i think we can all agree that errors are
Caption: best cause as early as possible
Caption: this is this from the uh nist
Caption: uh in the usa they they did a study and
Caption: they basically neatly demonstrated that
Caption: um the earlier you catch a bug i know
Caption: that these labels are really small but
Caption: basically these are costs going up the
Caption: later you find a bug so that's
Caption: production right over there on the on
Caption: the right side and
Caption: here the second one is when you're
Caption: actually writing the code so the ideal
Caption: time to catch a bug is back here even
Caption: before you write it preferably but if
Caption: you're the coder you just get given okay
Caption: do this
Caption: that's where you want to catch your bugs
Caption: you don't want them to slip out
Caption: further than that
Caption: so this is a point in favor of languages
Caption: with the static checking step because
Caption: they're going to catch a lot of these
Caption: ones early
Caption: and it's also a point in favor of tools
Caption: good ide tools because they're going to
Caption: just show you little red squiggles and
Caption: so on
Caption: another thing we can probably agree on
Caption: is that all code and data does have
Caption: types even if you're in a dynamic
Caption: language types are just the static facts
Caption: about the data in our programs so they
Caption: might be explicitly written into your
Caption: code or they might be implicit and
Caption: you've got to basically like run the
Caption: program in your head to work out what
Caption: the type of things are but either way
Caption: the types are there they're definitely
Caption: there
Caption: so another way of saying that there's no
Caption: such thing as typeless or schemeless
Caption: there's just type implicit or implicit
Caption: schemas
Caption: um
Caption: so you know things like dynamic code
Caption: javascript python things like that
Caption: schema-less databases no no sql things
Caption: like that
Caption: on the other hand types can be explicit
Caption: they can be part of the code or part of
Caption: the system so relational database
Caption: schemas they're explicit types you can
Caption: only do what what the explicit type says
Caption: things like classes in java or c-sharp
Caption: they're basically dictating what you can
Caption: and can't do with a piece of code and it
Caption: will not allow anything that doesn't
Caption: match the type so they're explicit types
Caption: more common ground
Caption: code it's for people and machines it's
Caption: not just for machines and it's not just
Caption: for people the machines have to be able
Caption: to read it and process it and execute it
Caption: but people are usually the ones who
Caption: write it so far at least
Caption: so what does it mean
Caption: well
Caption: types help document document and
Caption: communicate our intent so that's on the
Caption: human side so if you've got no types
Caption: that are explicit in your code then you
Caption: know you've got other issues with other
Caption: people coming along later and maybe not
Caption: understanding the
Caption: nuance of what you're trying to achieve
Caption: and that's where if you've got stringly
Caption: typed code in there it can easily be
Caption: changed by someone else who doesn't
Caption: understand the very careful way that you
Caption: were thinking of it running and then
Caption: they violated your ideas but none of
Caption: it's explicit so you know it it
Caption: even in a system like say express in
Caption: node it's a it's a web server system
Caption: it's not written in typescript it's
Caption: written in javascript there's no types
Caption: in the system but you go to the
Caption: documentation and it's basically just
Caption: showing you a whole bunch of types it's
Caption: showing you what all the properties are
Caption: and what types of values they accept
Caption: what all the functions are so the types
Caption: are there it's just you know are they
Caption: explicit in the code are they executable
Caption: documentation or are they kept in a
Caption: separate place
Caption: another point about this
Caption: people and machines um programming
Caption: languages and their type systems they
Caption: can be more or less expressive and they
Caption: can be more or less obtrusive and the
Caption: point i want to make here is that
Caption: if types and static types solved all of
Caption: our problems then why are dynamically
Caption: typed languages and nosql systems
Caption: thriving it's because you know they're
Caption: um low friction and they they're really
Caption: great in their niches so we haven't
Caption: really nailed it with type systems so
Caption: i'm really aware that i'm not saying
Caption: like hey do everything in types i'm
Caption: saying
Caption: um types solve some problems and
Caption: introduce different problems so there's
Caption: trade-offs
Caption: yeah simplicity versus complexity
Caption: okay
Caption: so
Caption: the typescript way i'd like to imagine
Caption: an elevator pitch by anders anders
Caption: heilsberg who invented typescript and a
Caption: few other languages the well-known ones
Caption: before that like delphi and c-sharp
Caption: given all these trade-offs how he might
Caption: pitch the idea for typescript and it'd
Caption: be something like this what if types
Caption: were optional
Caption: and they could actually describe our
Caption: real world coding patterns so the idea
Caption: would be you smash out some code
Caption: you do it
Caption: dynamic code style right you just get it
Caption: working don't worry about p appeasing
Caption: the compiler and then you have this type
Caption: system that you can come along later and
Caption: say okay now i want to
Caption: lock this in and say this is this is
Caption: what's allowed this is what's not
Caption: allowed and you can add this one later
Caption: on in fact that's how typescript largely
Caption: started most projects weren't written in
Caption: typescript at the time that it started
Caption: or very few none when it started
Caption: but what it could do was actually create
Caption: type definition files for existing
Caption: libraries things like express and
Caption: all kinds of things that were really
Caption: widely used out there
Caption: and it kind of bootstraps that way so
Caption: you could you could
Caption: want to do something with strong types
Caption: and then you could just get the types
Caption: from this definitely type repository and
Caption: then use express or use even now you can
Caption: do that you can use react you can use
Caption: whatever you want whether or not those
Caption: things are written doesn't matter
Caption: because the types are bolted on they
Caption: actually describe what this api does so
Caption: you can design an api without worrying
Caption: about oh will this work in a in a
Caption: specific kind of type system no you just
Caption: you just use the types to model what's
Caption: actually going on and what you get in
Caption: the end is something that looks really
Caption: different from
Caption: some of our better known static type
Caption: systems
Caption: do you know the book design patterns
Caption: gang of four it's pretty well well known
Caption: i really liked reading it at the time
Caption: but years and years later i've come to
Caption: realize with other systems that a lot of
Caption: those patterns actually start to look
Caption: like workarounds for
Caption: things that the the language or the type
Caption: system can't easily express
Caption: so for example decorate a pattern that's
Caption: one of these design patterns from this
Caption: gang of four book
Caption: i just wanted to illustrate a diagram of
Caption: you know
Caption: it's a class diagram with decorators
Caption: there's some interfaces there's some
Caption: concrete implementations
Caption: i won't go into all the details of that
Caption: but if you have to actually do a general
Caption: purpose decorator in a typical
Caption: object oriented statically typed
Caption: language it can be really difficult and
Caption: i remember trying to do some of these
Caption: trying to solve the general problem not
Caption: just with this one specific case and you
Caption: end up with a reflection code where you
Caption: go through and try and work out what the
Caption: type actually is at runtime write some
Caption: code to do the thing that you're trying
Caption: to do with it to decorate in some way
Caption: and then use this emit code to at
Caption: runtime generate new
Caption: dlls and and things that you can then
Caption: inject into your running code and in the
Caption: end it's really really complicated in
Caption: javascript here's a spy function i want
Caption: to just wrap any function you give me so
Caption: that when i call it something gets
Caption: logged out and it logs what the
Caption: arguments it was called with and what
Caption: the return value was and that's the
Caption: whole thing there
Caption: so here's my spy function i just pass it
Caption: a function and it's going to return
Caption: another function that has got this spy
Caption: built in so there's the function it
Caption: returns here's it calling your function
Caption: here's it's logging and here's it's
Caption: returning the return value so you've
Caption: just wrapped a function you've just
Caption: decorated in a couple of lines of code
Caption: and here's the typescript definition for
Caption: that it's just basically saying well
Caption: this the type of this thing
Caption: spy
Caption: it's it takes a function of a specific
Caption: shape f which we've made generic so
Caption: whatever shape of function you put in
Caption: we'll call that f and it returns one of
Caption: the same shape
Caption: we've just modeled what you've done so
Caption: the actual implementation was super easy
Caption: in a dynamic language and then the the
Caption: type description is 100 accurate and
Caption: also extremely easy to express
Caption: so we're talking best of both worlds
Caption: ideally rapid prototyping short succinct
Caption: code
Caption: accurate type checking and it's type
Caption: safe and it's scalable
Caption: so
Caption: that's the that would be the elevator
Caption: pitch
Caption: do both but how would you actually
Caption: achieve that so that's where it comes
Caption: down to the actual type system
Caption: types starting with types that model
Caption: what we actually do so for example in
Caption: typescript you can have single values
Caption: that are actually types so we've got an
Caption: apple type and orange type and you can
Caption: only put the string apple that lowercase
Caption: set of characters there that's the only
Caption: thing you'll accept if you try and
Caption: assign a value pair to a variable that
Caption: can only accept this apple string you
Caption: just can't do that so they're all
Caption: strings
Caption: but the compiler has now got visibility
Caption: into what is allowed in those strings so
Caption: it's not just one big bag of any
Caption: possible sequence of characters all
Caption: being the same type
Caption: so these are called unit types or
Caption: literal types
Caption: from there it's kind of obvious that you
Caption: want unions of types and this is another
Caption: thing that a lot of languages uh find it
Caption: very hard to express so a coin toss is
Caption: just we want to express that in our
Caption: program as the string heads or the
Caption: string tails and we don't want to accept
Caption: anything else because we don't want to
Caption: have like typos and things going on so
Caption: we can have a type coin toss and we can
Caption: write a function that accepts a coin
Caption: toss and they're the only two values
Caption: it's going to accept and the compiler
Caption: will check that and it won't allow
Caption: anything else
Caption: intersections of type this is one where
Caption: it's a little bit harder to explain but
Caption: the the example i came up with here is
Caption: that you know imagine we've got a couple
Caption: of objects which are just full of
Caption: properties they're just sort of record
Caption: types so we've got one with the foo
Caption: numeric and a bar string property and we
Caption: can merge those two types together what
Caption: would be the type of the resulting type
Caption: of merging these two things together so
Caption: that they had both properties well it'd
Caption: be the intersection a and b it's the
Caption: intersection of those two so you can
Caption: just express that in the type system you
Caption: can write this code that merges things
Caption: and then you've got a type that
Caption: describes
Caption: what what the result would look like
Caption: in a static way that that the compiler
Caption: can actually check
Caption: another really interesting um
Caption: development with typescript is narrowing
Caption: so uh here it's really common to have
Caption: things like nullable types so here's an
Caption: example where we've got a date but we're
Caption: not sure it might actually be undefined
Caption: maybe it was an optional property from
Caption: somewhere if we try to call a property
Caption: on that with typescript it's going to
Caption: tell us that we can't because it might
Caption: be undefined and you can't do that with
Caption: undefined so statically it's saying
Caption: that's not right there's a red squiggle
Caption: there in your ide here we've got a type
Caption: guard so we're actually going well if
Caption: date's not undefined now i'm doing
Caption: exactly the same thing syntactically
Caption: it's exactly the same thing but now it's
Caption: okay because it's narrowed the type so
Caption: inside that block it's it recognizes
Caption: well the type's not date or undefined
Caption: anymore it's just date so it allows this
Caption: thing and this can get really
Caption: sophisticated and it just models what
Caption: you actually do in your real code
Caption: finally
Caption: structural typing so what this means is
Caption: that most most type systems are nominal
Caption: so you know if you need to pass an
Caption: instance of a certain class to a
Caption: function you've got to get an instance
Caption: of that specific class you can't just
Caption: pass in something that's got similar
Caption: properties or whatever
Caption: the opposite of that is a structural
Caption: type system basically it's duct type if
Caption: it looks like a duck quacks like a duck
Caption: it's a duck so
Caption: our options object here takes a name and
Caption: account and here i can just simply make
Caption: up my own object that's got a name and
Caption: account pass it in there i don't need a
Caption: constructor i don't need to find out
Caption: where your options object constructor is
Caption: or a factory or anything like that i
Caption: just make up an object that's got a name
Caption: and account that's fine it's as good as
Caption: anything else
Caption: i couldn't resist just putting this
Caption: quick slide in here
Caption: because
Caption: the the types can get really really
Caption: sophisticated uh someone pointed out a
Caption: while ago that the type system is now
Caption: turing complete in typescript um i've
Caption: got a little
Caption: demo here of
Caption: what someone did with that so i'm not
Caption: suggesting you do this at home but um
Caption: what's happening here is it's not
Caption: running yeah it is
Caption: um this is this is basically uh
Caption: some database records but here we're
Caption: getting the type of these records and
Caption: typescript is able to infer all the
Caption: specific
Caption: strings and numbers and things in there
Caption: and then these are some queries actually
Caption: run at the type level
Caption: and
Caption: okay it doesn't actually seem to be
Caption: running okay technical problem there but
Caption: what goes on is that these strings are
Caption: actually these literal string types and
Caption: if you hover over the types here it
Caption: actually shows you
Caption: the result
Caption: like as if you just executed this query
Caption: and it will list bart and lisa and
Caption: things like that and you can go and
Caption: change that but none of this is running
Caption: there's no program running here if you
Caption: run this nothing happens because the
Caption: types don't exist at runtime anymore so
Caption: these are just running in the compiler
Caption: as you compile the code you modify the
Caption: code it's basically able to do arbitrary
Caption: computations
Caption: um maybe not so useful thing to do in
Caption: most of our code but it is very useful
Caption: for other things like um
Caption: accurately typing rest apis graph fuel
Caption: apis things like that
Caption: okay finally let's go into some
Caption: more specific ones and see if we can
Caption: just type some code the way these
Caption: stringly typed examples that we had in
Caption: the beginning in a safer way what we're
Caption: going to try and do is aim for 100
Caption: accuracy with our types but also trying
Caption: to be really unobtrusive because i think
Caption: that's what touchscreen really brings to
Caption: the table so that first one i'm not
Caption: going to spend really much time on this
Caption: this is the bread and butter of type
Caption: systems right so here you know we've got
Caption: some things that are right some things
Caption: that are wrong maybe the apis aren't
Caption: even consistent so everyone's going to
Caption: make mistakes like this you can't really
Caption: get around it and that's generally not a
Caption: problem if you're already using static
Caption: languages they're all over there but the
Caption: thing to remember is that properties in
Caption: dynamic languages are effectively
Caption: strings they're looked up as strings so
Caption: it doesn't know dynamic language doesn't
Caption: know if that's correct or not because
Caption: it's basically looking up a property bag
Caption: and just seeing it runtime if it's there
Caption: or not so with typescript you can say no
Caption: no it's not just a property bag it's got
Caption: these specific things on it so the
Caption: solution here really is just to use
Caption: typescript or some other statically
Caption: typed language that's you won't have
Caption: type of problems anymore so let's move
Caption: on from that one
Caption: the second problem
Caption: we mentioned implicit connections
Caption: between things so a little bit more of a
Caption: fuller example here now but still very
Caption: simple so this is a single file
Caption: component in view i've got a template up
Caption: here what i want to note is that
Caption: effectively this whole template is a
Caption: string it's opaque the compiler can't
Caption: work out what that means or what it is
Caption: so down here
Caption: we've actually this is already in an
Caption: error state because up here we're trying
Caption: to inject something called name but we
Caption: don't have name down here we've got
Caption: first name and last name but there's no
Caption: build error there's no warning there so
Caption: how can we improve on that well in this
Caption: specific case i really think
Caption: this is a strong case for using things
Caption: like jsx or tsx where you actually do
Caption: your
Caption: html templating or html view you do it
Caption: in the code
Caption: the reason for that is that the type
Caption: system now in typescript is able to work
Caption: out that there is a single definition of
Caption: this name and that this refers to the
Caption: same one if you refactor name it will
Caption: automatically change this if you just
Caption: type something different there you're
Caption: going to get a red squiggle here because
Caption: there's going to be nothing called name
Caption: so you can get rid of your your problems
Caption: in this case pretty easily like that
Caption: there's other examples we could do but
Caption: i'm just going to move on to others now
Caption: um we talked about these transposed
Caption: values i had that sending email and you
Caption: couldn't really work out which way
Caption: around it went and this is the classic
Caption: mr bean problem when he's trying to do
Caption: his own filling and he realizes at some
Caption: point that the dentist thing can go all
Caption: kinds of ways so um how does the type
Caption: system help here well it really can't
Caption: because they're all strings it doesn't
Caption: know what the the correct order is it's
Caption: up to you to figure out that you pass
Caption: the correct things in the correct
Caption: positions because this is these are
Caption: positional parameters
Caption: so this is stringly type code if you
Caption: look up blogs on what is stringly type
Caption: code you get examples like that but i
Caption: would say the solution is not really
Caption: about the strings themselves it's just
Caption: about the positional ordering of the
Caption: parameters
Caption: my preferred solution for this is just
Caption: past by name and some languages have
Caption: direct support path by name but a lot
Caption: don't and in javascript you can just
Caption: basically say well instead of accepting
Caption: three parameters i'm going to accept a
Caption: single parameter and i've just called
Caption: this one options and it's an object and
Caption: it's got properties and the properties
Caption: are the things i want to get and i'm
Caption: just going to have this one parameter
Caption: now when you call it
Caption: here's the call down here i've just
Caption: basically fetched these these host user
Caption: and password from somewhere and the only
Caption: difference here is the extra curl is
Caption: here because we're constructing a
Caption: shorthand object with those properties
Caption: in it and just passing that one thing to
Caption: the function
Caption: so
Caption: we it's still stringy right like there's
Caption: still strings in there but now
Caption: everything has to effectively be named
Caption: the names are checked they have to match
Caption: you can't have the wrong things in there
Caption: you can't have anything missing you
Caption: can't have anything additional that that
Caption: doesn't belong
Caption: and that just basically feeds off
Caption: structural typing structural typing
Caption: makes that possible it's way harder to
Caption: get this accidentally wrong as a bonus
Caption: the order doesn't matter anymore you put
Caption: these things in any order you want also
Caption: remember we were talking before about
Caption: code tends to change and one of the
Caption: classic things that happens is that
Caption: functions take on new options or new
Caption: parameters um when you list them all out
Caption: there you might end up with say an
Caption: optional one and then someone comes up
Caption: with the next api you need another
Caption: required one well now you've got to have
Caption: some weird overloads and do a lot of
Caption: stuff here you can
Caption: you can make any of these optional you
Caption: can add new things all the time and
Caption: you're not going to break the api you
Caption: just got additional things that weren't
Caption: supported before
Caption: okay now this fourth problem we're
Caption: talking about apples to oranges and the
Caption: example i had before was feet and meters
Caption: so we had units of measure now i've got
Caption: one that's actually string related so
Caption: i've got a function that sort of by
Caption: looking at it um it looks like what it
Caption: wants is an absolute path and i've
Caption: called it with a relative path so
Caption: semantically there's an error here but
Caption: the type system is not helping me
Caption: because
Caption: in fact an absolute part is just going
Caption: to be a string and this relative path is
Caption: just a string a string is a string so i
Caption: can pass that the compiler says yeah it
Caption: looks fine to me and then you maybe do
Caption: the wrong thing at runtime delete the
Caption: wrong file send send the wrong person
Caption: the wrong information whatever
Caption: um
Caption: i mean how could we work around that how
Caption: is the type system going to be able to
Caption: tell a relative path from an absolute
Caption: path that's one where typescript has got
Caption: some tricks up at sleeve um the first
Caption: one i'll look at is
Caption: wrapper types and this is more of a
Caption: classic approach in a lot of
Caption: object-oriented type systems where you'd
Caption: create a class and you'd wrap that and
Caption: so basically now your api is going to
Caption: revolve around instances of this
Caption: absolute path class so you can't just
Caption: pass in a string you've got to
Caption: instantiate this absolute path or get
Caption: one from somewhere from maybe from some
Caption: other api and now you can process a file
Caption: because that's the only thing it's going
Caption: to accept um
Caption: it works it's good we got rid of the
Caption: strings but it's actually not my
Caption: preference because it it introduces
Caption: marshalling and conversion boilerplate
Caption: you've got a type now that you've got to
Caption: worry about and if you if these things
Caption: were going to and from a database
Caption: whatever you probably just want to store
Caption: the path as a string right you can't
Caption: store the actual class so you've got to
Caption: have conversion codes serialization
Caption: deserialization it doesn't quite look
Caption: like the simple version we started with
Caption: we've added complexity
Caption: and it doesn't interoperate as easily
Caption: because now you've got your own custom
Caption: way of handling
Caption: this specific data type but absolute
Caption: paths work in lots of places right but
Caption: yours no yours don't now
Caption: also it's still easy to construct
Caption: a invalid path but with no build no
Caption: early warning so here here's one where
Caption: i've i've just passed the relative path
Caption: to the constructor it'll fail at runtime
Caption: but the whole point here that we're
Caption: talking about is trying to catch errors
Caption: early right so could we do better could
Caption: we make it fail even earlier than that
Caption: so my preferred solution here is what's
Caption: called branded types
Caption: um
Caption: this is still a stringy solution uh it's
Caption: got a weird thing here where we're just
Caption: saying the absolute yeah it's just a
Caption: string but we're using this intersection
Caption: type and we're saying it's a string but
Caption: it also has this weird extra property
Caption: with this brand in an absolute path
Caption: brand
Caption: um
Caption: just to summarize
Caption: a branded type is a
Caption: thing that only exists in the compiler
Caption: this all goes away at runtime and in
Caption: fact the only reference to this property
Caption: is here in this type we never at runtime
Caption: when we when we're checking if
Caption: something's an absolute path we never
Caption: actually give it this property or we
Caption: don't have to check for the property so
Caption: what what is going on here well we've
Caption: got a couple of advanced types in here i
Caption: i won't go through it all but let's just
Caption: say
Caption: let's just go through what's happening
Caption: down here so it looks a bit like the
Caption: last one where now we need an absolute
Caption: path but it's actually just a string so
Caption: we can just call we can have a string
Caption: here so this is an absolute path
Caption: and we're calling process file but it's
Caption: not satisfied because it doesn't know
Caption: that this is an absolute path it's just
Caption: a string
Caption: so
Caption: it's going to say no you can't do that
Caption: because this thing requires an absolute
Caption: path which has this extra brand thing on
Caption: it and this one doesn't have a brand
Caption: it's just a string so no you're not
Caption: allowed to do that well that's good we
Caption: didn't want that to work but i mean you
Caption: can't pass any string to this now so how
Caption: do you satisfy it well this is the
Caption: magical part so we've got what's called
Caption: a type guard here so we're saying is
Caption: this p an absolute path and this is just
Caption: a boolean returning function just
Caption: returns true or false but actually the
Caption: return type annotation is basically
Caption: saying if this returns true
Caption: you have established that p is an
Caption: absolute path
Caption: so the compiler works backwards it also
Caption: has special handling for assertion
Caption: function so it says when we get to this
Caption: last line which is now okay by the way
Caption: so here this one this one didn't build
Caption: but this one exactly the same with
Caption: exactly the same string this one passes
Caption: so something special happened here the
Caption: compiler reasoned that the only way we
Caption: could get to this line 19 is if the
Caption: assertion succeeded otherwise it would
Caption: have thrown we never would have gotten
Caption: there
Caption: he was going to sleep
Caption: so the only way the assertion could have
Caption: passed is that this this function
Caption: returned true so basically our typeguard
Caption: fail the type system knows statically
Caption: without running your code the only way
Caption: you can get here is that this returned
Caption: true and if this returned true you've
Caption: told the type system that that must be
Caption: an absolute path so you check it at
Caption: runtime but the type system knows well
Caption: when you're calling it here it must be
Caption: an absolute part so we've effectively
Caption: taken a general type like string and
Caption: we've branded it with a with
Caption: additional knowledge that can now be
Caption: used in apis passed around the system
Caption: and the
Caption: type system can reason about that and
Caption: the cool thing is that you end up with
Caption: simple strings in the code you don't
Caption: actually see the types down here you
Caption: basically just write your code as you
Caption: did and it'll warn you when you haven't
Caption: checked something and you put in some
Caption: runtime checks which is really what you
Caption: want because they're going to catch
Caption: those but your errors are going to
Caption: happen statically you're going to be
Caption: told straight away
Caption: so
Caption: another one of the problems we looked at
Caption: was conflicting definitions so we've got
Caption: environment variables process dot end in
Caption: node is where you access your property
Caption: bag which is full of the environment
Caption: variables you can't avoid these being
Caption: strings the property names of the
Caption: environment variables are strings and
Caption: the values all come through as strings
Caption: and these are from outside the system
Caption: boundary so you can't type that you
Caption: can't tell it well this is what's going
Caption: to be in the environment well you don't
Caption: know you run the program it could be
Caption: anything in there
Caption: so this is kind of like a standard
Caption: approach right because you're just
Caption: dealing you would do this in a
Caption: statically typed language as well you'd
Caption: have a kind of property bag you don't
Caption: know what's in there you reach and you
Caption: look for a
Caption: stringly named property and you've got a
Caption: string value and then you might do some
Caption: things to it convert it apply some
Caption: defaults
Caption: but we've got several problems in here
Caption: these aren't actually
Caption: consistently doing the same thing so
Caption: this one treats food level as a number
Caption: well that's fine let's look at this one
Caption: so the foo enabled
Caption: it comes in as a string but if it's not
Caption: present then it gives it a value one as
Caption: a string and then it parses that so this
Caption: is actually kind of clever right so it's
Caption: like in the in your environment you
Caption: could pass a one or a zero or the word
Caption: true or the word false and when you pass
Caption: that you're going to get a truthy or a
Caption: false value and then you do your stuff
Caption: but down here oh here we go so we're
Caption: using foo enabled but we're just
Caption: checking the raw value so basically
Caption: if it's not present then it's not
Caption: enabled but if anything is present there
Caption: the string true the string false this is
Caption: all truthy to javascript so if you put
Caption: in the string false
Caption: that check is going to go oh it's
Caption: actually enabled and it's going to run
Caption: the wrong piece of code and there's no
Caption: early warning for that and we've got one
Caption: down here and this is particularly
Caption: insidious for
Caption: brutalizing systems making systems
Caption: brittle is that we're not actually
Caption: literally referring so even if you did a
Caption: search looking for all the instances
Caption: where a particular
Caption: environment variable was referenced you
Caption: wouldn't find them here because we're
Caption: actually dynamically
Caption: coming up with the names mapping and
Caption: then and then checking them that way
Caption: so there's a few problems in there
Caption: um
Caption: the main solution i would come up with
Caption: here is just it are still a stringy
Caption: solution because like i said you can't
Caption: get rid of those strings out of the
Caption: environment variables
Caption: but what we can do is we can put them
Caption: all in one place single source of truth
Caption: have a single config file that's the
Caption: only place that's allowed to read from
Caption: process.n what you do in there is you do
Caption: all your validation all your conversions
Caption: and all your defaults they all live
Caption: there the rest of your system this is
Caption: what we had before but now it's
Caption: referring to those so you take in all of
Caption: that loose messy outside world stuff
Caption: but you expose inside your system
Caption: something neat typed single source of
Caption: truth completely consistent
Caption: so we're still dealing with strings but
Caption: we've just changed the way we've written
Caption: that we're going to deal we won't have
Caption: all these problems with inconsistent
Caption: definitions or refactorings anymore
Caption: final one brittle control flow so i've
Caption: got a slightly different example here
Caption: which we're calculating the area of a
Caption: square or a circle it's important to
Caption: read this comment right because what
Caption: it's doing is it's saying well if it's a
Caption: square then we square the length if it's
Caption: a circle we do this but the default case
Caption: well we never reach here lol so let's
Caption: just return 42 because it's the same
Caption: type and we're not going to reach there
Caption: anyway because we've told them right at
Caption: the start that it's only for squares and
Caption: circles right so they shouldn't pass in
Caption: anything else but of course you know
Caption: some someone has actually passed in a
Caption: rectangle and instead of getting an
Caption: error or something like that they're
Caption: actually getting the number 42
Caption: also the person who actually put in the
Caption: legitimate square also got 42 because
Caption: there's a spelling mistake in here
Caption: because it's just a string and it
Caption: doesn't know what these strings are and
Caption: the person who passed in a circle got
Caption: not a number
Caption: because there's a typo in the radius up
Caption: there so that's why i call this brittle
Caption: control flow there's so many things that
Caption: can go wrong and you don't know you
Caption: don't find out about any of these things
Caption: until runtime
Caption: so the classic solution in oo would be
Caption: to actually create a hierarchy of types
Caption: have a abstract base class for a shape
Caption: create a square class create a circle
Caption: class do things like that
Caption: and then the area function would
Caption: actually be a method in there and so
Caption: each of these would implement its own it
Caption: solves a problem there's no more strings
Caption: it's not my preferred approach though
Caption: because again you end up with this kind
Caption: of conversion boilerplate so now if
Caption: shapes were things you were storing in
Caption: the database or receiving over the wire
Caption: you've now got to marshal them to and
Caption: from your your representation of shape
Caption: so you've got this additional complexity
Caption: in your code
Caption: also
Caption: that's for another talk but there's
Caption: taxonomy problems with these classic you
Caption: know single hierarchy taxonomies it's
Caption: not really easy to model everything in
Caption: that that constrained way
Caption: there are solutions for that but we
Caption: won't go into that but you know it can
Caption: get hard can get boilerplatey um and
Caption: also you still don't have a lot of
Caption: control over subclassing and things like
Caption: that so
Caption: it's not my preferred i think we could
Caption: do better another classic is using an
Caption: enumeration so now it's like well we can
Caption: only have shapes and sorry squares and
Caption: circles now because we're going to
Caption: create an enumerated kind and our shape
Caption: is going to have only one of those kinds
Caption: so the compiler can check it can only be
Caption: this or that but there is this extra
Caption: information we've got to drag around and
Caption: not everything has everything so we've
Caption: got like optional length and optional
Caption: radius because some things might have
Caption: length some things might have a radius
Caption: um so now it looks a bit like our
Caption: original code but instead of strings
Caption: we've got enumerated type so it's cool
Caption: we can check those and if you put in the
Caption: wrong thing it won't build
Caption: the the issue is that you don't get
Caption: strong checking over here because
Caption: they're all optional properties and
Caption: anything could use anything else and
Caption: you're not really sure which one's which
Caption: um so i think we could do better than
Caption: that again so my preferred approach is
Caption: actually um
Caption: what we call a discriminated union so
Caption: now the actual function itself looks
Caption: pretty much identical to the original
Caption: um what we've done is we've introduced a
Caption: square type that just has a kind square
Caption: and a length and a circle type it has a
Caption: kind circle and a radius so that's the
Caption: only thing that a circle can be it's the
Caption: only thing that a square can be and our
Caption: shape is now just the union of the two a
Caption: shape is a circle or a square it can't
Caption: be anything else
Caption: now we can actually
Caption: pass in using structural typing just
Caption: instances of squares and circles we get
Caption: the right things
Caption: all of this stuff has to be correct it
Caption: won't build otherwise you can't have
Caption: typos here because it's like well that
Caption: is not a valid circle or that's not a
Caption: valid square you can't refer to the
Caption: length on a circle or the radius of a
Caption: square because it works out when you're
Caption: in here it narrows the type down and it
Caption: knows it can only be that thing
Caption: and the other thing is
Caption: often in systems when they expand you
Caption: get new cases right so if there were new
Caption: cases how would we know about it here
Caption: well
Caption: the type system can also work out the
Caption: exhaustiveness of your of your casing
Caption: or if you've deprecated and removed one
Caption: it'll tell you well that's no longer a
Caption: valid shape so
Caption: as you
Caption: maintain and change your system you get
Caption: all these early warnings which is really
Caption: great
Caption: okay so in conclusion good strings are
Caption: good
Caption: don't believe what you've been told
Caption: never use strings strings are bad
Caption: it really depends on the tools that
Caption: you've got so i'd say the key takeaways
Caption: are explicit types
Caption: first of all is what we covered earlier
Caption: on you know they really help humans and
Caption: tools
Caption: and in typescript i would say when it
Caption: comes to stringly type code feel free to
Caption: keep using strings just make sure that
Caption: they're part of the type system that
Caption: there's visibility on them so they're
Caption: often natural they often keep the code
Caption: simple and they make it look like what
Caption: you'd write if you were writing
Caption: dynamically but you can make them really
Caption: strongly checked and they help you avoid
Caption: a lot of conversion boilerplate
Caption: um make sure you've got a single source
Caption: of truth because that's another thing
Caption: that comes that bites you in a lot of
Caption: these cases
Caption: uh aim for 100 accuracy why not you know
Caption: if you can model just about anything
Caption: with a type system then don't leave gaps
Caption: make it really accurate and then you'll
Caption: catch all of these things before you go
Caption: to production
Caption: uh and finally
Caption: this is a preference for me make your
Caption: types as unobtrusive as you can
Caption: so
Caption: you want to model the natural solution
Caption: the thing you'd write if you weren't
Caption: worrying about the types
Caption: and you know typestrip's really good for
Caption: letting you be able to do that ideally
Caption: an api should look like the untyped code
Caption: and it won't even be full of type
Caption: annotations they'll all be inferred
Caption: and it just helps you avoid boil plate
Caption: so that's it thanks for listening
Caption: any questions